have you guys been following impeachment
at all oh yeah I saw a bunch of stuff
today that I thought was some really
great videos that yeah pushes back on
there's some there's some big stuff so I
I I I don't care about impeachment to be
completely honest but I do care about
culture War stuff so we in the
impeachment today
the Trump's lawyers finally started
snapping back in a very powerful way no
reason this I care about I think the
impeach itself's a foregone conclusion
is a waste of time he's not going to be
convicted I mean maybe sure but I just
doubt it
but there was there was a few instances
one the the Trump's lawyers brought up
Kamala Harris fundraising for these
rioters and advocating for violence and
riots and protest and then the the
impeachment managers guy wrestling he's
like I I don't seem to recall kamalaris
ever saying these things dude walks back
up from Trump's side and he goes we
played the video here three times what
do you mean then they showed these
videos of all the Democrats calling for
all this craziness they show all the
videos of the riots and it was like I
hope regular Americans saw all that that
was the opportunity the first the first
time to point out the Democrats are
doing and that's it there's there's no
real trial here right the impeachment
isn't actually due process so it's
stupid to come out and try and treat it
like an actual court case 100 it's an
Optics propaganda War oh I mean like
look at it with the uh Capital thing
whether you think that's real or fake or
whatever that is I mean you had all
these people in Hollywood go nuts I
can't believe that you can't do that to
the Capitol and these are the same
people that were like match match match
to all these antifa people getting
arrested for riding and burning down
poor people and middle class people's
businesses it's the exact same thing
yup that's impeachment yeah but it did
feel good because I've been avoiding the
impeachment stuff just because it's so
boring and pointless it is pointless but
in in the beginning Trump's lawyers are
doing pretty bad and now I'm seeing
these videos pop up where I'm like hey
this is pretty good because because the
Democrats don't have answers for this
how they've supported the violence for
this long but it does go hand in hand
with what we're saying about Cuomo I
think for one the riots were basically
them letting letting The Purge happen
destroy the small businesses Wipe Out
the the middle class and the working
class property and ownership so they
have nothing then they print all this
money give it to you only a little bit
but then everybody spends at the big box
stores that are allowed to stay open and
they're just siphoning away the assets
it's really funny this whole thing
everything that's happened the lockdowns
the rioting it really helps the great
reset you know the great reset 100 they
said at first in but in 2030 you'll own
nothing and you'll be happy well one way
to get people to own nothing is to lock
down their businesses by force and then
when their businesses can survive here's
the crazy thing about it right if you're
in a restaurant you're struggling
because your food went bad so there were
some restaurants where they were like we
got shut down for a month thirty
thousand dollars worth of food spoiled
and garbage if we want to reopen we got
to spend 30 grand what about a hard good
store maybe you sell skateboards or
t-shirts you're fine you got rent to
worry about and your and your personal
expenses but you can survive longer well
surprise surprise the riots shut up
smashed out your windows stole all your
stuff now your business is gone too how
convenient now you know you now you own
nothing the best part is the government
won't even give you a little bit for
food they're just leaving you hanging I
don't know I don't know what these
politicians expect to happen but it's
almost like they're supportive This was
meant to antagonize people particularly
Trump supporters are those who don't
like the riots the the the the far left
they seem to have been happy with it and
the Democrat establishment you know
cronies were happy with it now you get
this impeachment that's meant to be I
guess insult to injury the guy's not
even present anymore it seems like
everything they're doing is designed to
antagonize and just make
where you pack a dog into a corner and
you poke it with a stick until it lashes
out and bites you and then you blame the
dog for biting you and have it put to
sleep and like these these people are
watching it happen and because it's a
trump supporter in the corner that's
getting prodded or whoever and I'm not
saying it's happening but this is like
what I keep thinking they're okay with
it they're like yeah he's getting abused
oh he lashed out but it it comes out it
is happening the issue is we're not
saying it's a conspiracy or intentional
we're saying whatever the reason is
what's been happening over the past year
is essentially Democrats pushing people
into a corner and just whacking them
with a stick over and over again so it
doesn't matter if their intention was to
do that that's literally what's
happening don't get me wrong Republicans
are not getting a fight yeah for sure
Trump was the one who was like two
thousand dollars for everybody and it
was McConnell was like no well yeah well
I mean like here's the whole thing like
a lot of people think this reset is
about money and it's about power the
people doing this have more money
they'll ever spend in a billion
lifetimes and more power than I ever
said this is a spiritual thing this is a
spiritual war it's a spiritual attack
it's about stealing your loosh your
energy getting you so depressed and like
you know people are talking about the uh
here it's about to get weird but people
are talking about the age of Aquarius
and this uh enlightening and then you're
they're talking about hey man you know
uh transhumanism it's all about this
this realm that we live in and trapping
us here and just low frequency stuff
these Bill Gates has more money and
power than he'll ever have for a
thousand lifetimes he's all about your
energy and trapping you here and that's
what this all about crush your soul
crush your happiness make you miserable
so they feed off that well a lot of
people say the great reset will happen
well people need to understand the great
reset is happening 2020 was not just a
slap in the face but a low blow to all
the American people paying attention
especially all the American taxpayers
and small business owners that have been
ridiculed destroyed and just made to
look like utter fools and it was
absolutely sickening to see police
officers and there's some surveillance
camera footage that that has gone viral
in 2020 that shows police officers
walking in and just finding penalizing
and destroying the livelihoods of small
mommy pop shops as people are allowed to
coalesce in Walmart they're allowed to
be in Target they are allowed to be in
Best Buy but if you had a small business
the Jack boot officer would show up at
your door sometimes break down your
business store and say that's it I'm
taking everything for you because my
master Mr Como Mr Newsome told me to do
so and I as the raveling dog will do as
I'm told and I will bite you and take
away your food but listen it's simple
simple we brought this up many times
you're a cop you're making 30 40K a year
not a lot of money for these like you
know lower lower level guys entry level
you know officers and you're looking at
the devastation caused by the lockdowns
you're seeing the guy in the shop
begging please don't do this to me man I
can barely feed my family don't give me
that fine and that cop's gone glad it's
not me I'm getting my paycheck I'm with
you on that I'm with you but still it's
it's basically the there's no rule of
law anymore man I mean I know you some
people don't like that one letter the
17th letter whatever that and they're
all thought it was just to pacified
people I just don't know what people are
else they were supposed to do I mean
they pulled out their attention they
pulled out their money cable the
two-party system it's just that but we
have no rule of law the people who are
there to take the oath to defend the
Constitution are not doing it on a local
a state a federal and an international
level our military and our law
enforcement are not enforcing the laws
what else can we do they're of course in
the edict well this is the thing Tim
during the Nuremberg trials following
the the rules obeying your orders wasn't
an excuse it didn't matter uh people
were penalized and punished because they
did what they were told and and just be
because someone tells you to do it just
because you don't want to do you
understand you're part of the larger
system here the larger problem that is
perpetrating it and allowing it to get
this bad and it wouldn't be if you just
simply question yeah and actually did
your job that you're supposed to do
Under the letters well there's no
there's no simple action people can take
right you've got cops who are being told
as a pandemic people are dying this is
how we save their lives we have no
choice go to Walmart it's not the same
go to Costco listen go to Best Buy
Amazon's open yeah they're Amazon Fresh
show up to the Amazon warehouse then
don't show up to them
in L.A on Lankershim there's a billboard
that says Amazon Fresh along the lines
of this Amazon Fresh wide open come in
that is and as you go down Lankershim
every small business is closed this has
been done purposefully man and listen
when Authority comes across a resistance
it comes in the form of Riot police
every time everywhere the difference
between here and these third world
countries is they've seen a lot and the
margins of going like completely and
utterly broke is so much thinner we have
it good here a lot of people don't want
to rock the boat but guess what it's
just gonna they're just gonna keep
taking it it's dominoes falling over
there's no easy way because it's all
about confidence in Authority the
Constitution is meaningless the laws are
meaningless if Cuomo ordered the cops to
do something illegal they would just do
it right no no don't get me wrong a lot
of them have quit absolutely a lot of
cops around the country have quit and
they're now being replaced by
essentially scabs people who are willing
to work in violation of the law just
because the executive said to do it
there's got to be something going on
behind the scenes because this great
reset is not an American thing it's like
a glow Klaus Schwab is I don't know
could you be any have any more evil name
than clausch Klaus so I think you're
spot on with it being a war for your
spirit I don't know if they're behind
the scenes bending U.S law and just like
you know what we're just gonna go past
it let's make whatever pandemic so we
can suspend habeas corpus they won't
have you seen Bill Gates zeros patent
zero six zero six zero six they want to
put things in your body to track your
bio we've already gone over there maybe
they don't want to implant but it's a
real patent and they want to measure
your wearable they want to measure your
bio activity and then pay you crypto so
they can see if you're watching a
cartoon they'll pay you for that if you
watch that cartoon if you watch that
commercial you'll get paid for that they
wanna maybe eventually put your body in
a pod and give you money
already
The Matrix body heat thing made no sense
on purpose but they want to pay you for
your Biometrics it's very similar to The
Matrix what the 666 patent is about is
that they want you to take physical
activities in exchange for crypto yeah
basically what's happening is it's there
it's an authoritarian attempt at making
people we talked about this like
basically Get Back To Nature be more you
know sleeping in the in the flowers in
the fields we'll pay you for watching
cartoons gargling bacon for breakfast
they can pay you for watching and
commercials I really wanted like doll I
think they they think there's too many
people and they want to like start
controlling talks about it his his
father is it was a Eugenics this is a
fact his father was a Eugenics his
father Genesis
specifically had many times too uh well
this is another thing I think they're
really trying to make the world like
China I don't think it's over
consumption but I think it's seeing how
China runs there kind of uh government
runs their people and and trying to
exemplify it because if you look at even
Davos which is hosted by the world
economic Forum their first Speaker this
year was of course the president of
China and Klaus is there
good work I love you all like growling
over him he got the first say during the
world economic Forum today and he's like
this is great we need more economic
governance we need more economic
cooperation worldwide and this is
exactly what's happening here especially
with corporations like Disney and others
the Rothschilds the Pope I sound like
I'm talking hyperbolic stuff but look up
the Rothschilds Pope Alliance they're
the ones bringing all the major
corporations into pushing for the great
research operation gelato I think it's
called well no no no there was even a
mainstream media article we could
probably pull it up talking about how uh
you know the Rothschilds were
specifically bringing together a lot of
top banks on Wall Street a lot of major
corporations a lot of big Pharma
organizations to push for This Global
reset which is a great idea I shared the
article with you uh as well Tim and we
talked about it on the show mainstream
media let's talk about this issue is
this Communism had a lot of power the
Soviet Union killed a lot of people
these communist Nations killed a lot of
people Mountains of Skulls who was
talking about that and was it bright
Matt Brainerd and Cambodia yeah Cambodia
and so the problem was
America
Freedom Constitution Liberty First
Second Amendment third fourth fifth
sixth seven eight nine you get the point
so if you want to have communism the
authoritarians can do it they can
suppress and oppress and kill hundreds
of millions of people the problem is so
long as those people know Freedom exists
they will do everything in their power
to jump over that wall to find Freedom
and communism but when monarchy also is
a big problem well so with commentary
with authoritarianism you had when they
were building the anti-fascist
protection Rampart in in Germany you
know that is right the Berlin Wall it
was called the anti-fascist production
Rampart you had people fleeing their
homes full speed to cross before the
wall got built because they knew what
was coming
when the wall was built I think the
first person who died was this young guy
who tried jumping the wall and they
killed him they didn't want their
subjects the slaves of their of the
Communist you know Union to escape
because they needed people to work as
effectively slaves once the people knew
that freedom was just on the other side
they would risk their lives to get it so
these people the authoritarian Wingnuts
like the Chinese Communist party no the
only thing standing in their way from
implementing total Global
authoritarianism is a country like
America with a constitution with freedom
with the Bill of Rights so you have to
destroy it and erode it from within once
America is gone there will be no land of
the free there will be no idea of
freedom and there will be nowhere to run
there won't be a wall you can jump over
no matter where you go you do as you're
told or you get the worst of it that's
where we're heading towards and you know
I know I know a lot of people on the
left might say oh you're being
hyperbolic I don't care you're not
paying attention yeah you're looking at
what you look at what's going on with
the government literally shutting
everything down without any scientific
evidence being wrong every other step
every step of the way and destroying the
lives of people every single day at a
certain point you have to ask yourself
why they're doing it yeah bro another
thing to really I'm sorry you know I
really want to bring this up to
especially along with China we also
found out today that they blocked the
World Health Organization from accessing
critical data to find out where where
this sickness came from they actually
blocked information going around from
the first people that got sick and were
living in a government right now that's
acquiescing to China in a way where Joe
Biden signs an executive order saying
you could no longer say the China virus
as he's talking about the UK variant
non-stop so so there's a double standard
here there's obviously something going
on here that doesn't add up doesn't make
sense and for the World Health
Organization to Puppeteer the official
lines of Beijing after only spending
three hours in that laboratory in Wuhan
after not getting the critical data to
even assess how this started is
absolutely sickening listen it all goes
back to that nobody knows history nobody
studies history the fact that BLM was
started by black lesbian marxists means
that I don't know how you can be a
Marxist and be those two things because
if you study communism the first thing
that happens pretty like he was like
anti-lgbtq okay look at look at China
look at look at Russia dude the first
thing communism does is it it just it it
pushes it's authoritarianism because
fascists did the same thing both
extremist ideologies that were taking
over Europe wanted very similar things
and the only real difference in my
opinion was the words they used to
describe themselves but but if you look
at China you look at Russia which is a
communism they marginalize women
ethnic minorities and gays it happens I
dude I was supposed to do stand-up this
is about 10 years ago in China and I
gotta be honest with you man when you go
around China the people are the people
are nice it's always the governments man
it's always the government and what's
supposed to do stand up at this hard
rock and uh they told me two weeks
before they were supposed to have the
first ever
um national uh Mr Gay Chinese uh
competition and the government came down
and shut it down because they didn't
want to talk about it look at what's
going on we talked about this a couple
days ago in the United States they're
saying you know masculinity is bad we do
these Gillette commercials where they
say toxic masculinity all that stuff in
China they're doing the opposite in
China they're they're training young men
to be more masculine this is a big thing
they're working on yeah this this is
what really gets me is seeing people
wear check of our shirts because there's
many reports many accounts of him being
a racist homophobic mass murderer and
specifically being specifically cruel to
individuals of color and individuals who
were gay so so why is he somebody I mean
he was racist because he's a beautiful
huge races people are obsessed with
Charisma he was charismatic and
beautiful so people didn't know that he
would I don't think he was well liked he
was young he was smart and he was he was
he had a beautiful smile he would blow
people's brains out for fun he was a nut
job but people wear a shirt because he's
an attractive guy yeah psychotic I mean
like they walk around crying about Nazis
with NASA t-shirts on I mean they have
no clue of History okay operation
Project Paperclip yeah we just talked
about it the Japanese unit that we took
all their data 731 thanks for checking
out this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
timcast IRL Monday through Friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
Super Chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time